hey guys so guess what we're at the  airport again and we just got back from  Australia and now we're on our way to  London for college any chance  Francesco's here we have so much luggage  I don't even know what my baggage weight  was 44  what time is it in London so we just got  in here to London and I've completely  already destroyed this hotel room but  it's so cute it has all these crazy  things that you can just like do on this  tablet I can control plus say pretty  much all of the things mood give me  change change change Serena I'm heading  to go to dinner with Becky who I have  been watching her on YouTube I think it  was like 2007 maybe like late 2006 when  I first found her I don't know what it  was but it was a long time ago so my  blog outlet right jump around guys I  just wanna let everyone know I'm going  to start vlogging don't think bad  I mean